by asking this question of whether the
Obama administration will improve the
state of the world we're implicitly
saying we have great expectations the
Obama administration will make the world
a better place on that I have to give a
resounding yes the answer is no way no
because Obama is no vote or I think you
are to change the world in 2008 being
the first colored person to be elected
president of the United States me myself
being asian-american I you know I feel
more confident about you know my future
generations if not this generation you
know three generations from now we might
see an asian president or latina don't
matter now he's broken status quo for
presidency the Obama administration hope
for the better you bet fact that he just
happens to be a black man will change
the way that people view our country
forever I'm really serious when I'm
walking around talking about how
Americans are being perceived different
overseas my buddy here just said it what
i considered very poetically is that
we're in a situation now where you know
what people are going to look at the
world a little bit different barack
obama is not for black he's not for why
he's not for red blue green is for
everybody yeah first off he will
definitely change this country obviously
he's going to change America mostly
because his policies are so different
from President Bush's obviously the way
he'll do things the wake of run some of
the laws that will be enacted in his
time in office the country will change
now the same reason I believe that he
will also change the world I hope that
mr. Obama was succeeded and change
outside the united states and also
succeeded in changing the way we are
looking towards the united states and
its people i do believe that Obama can
bring change in this world if he stays
committed to the same value that brought
him the presidency
that value of a genuine person Obama has
this unique and the team behind him
physical team has this unique
opportunity um to to make a difference
because people trust him Obama is not
alone he has his cabinet he has his team
and has all the supporters around the
room is not just a bad it's the world
would've only suggest we can didn't say
as I can he said we and let's be the
people